game film food
logo the four channels live together in
harmony but then everything changed when
the YouTube algorithm attacked only
matpat master of all four theories could
bring bounds to the channels but when
YouTube needed him most he vanished but
I believe that map pack can save the
world
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's here to reveal your
secret power subscription bending try it
out click the button below the video to
transform it now I don't often call a
lot of things perfect almost anything
can be improved upon in one way or
another but up there with Chrono Trigger
the Lord of the Rings and the sweet
delicious burn of Diet Coke is Avatar
The Last Airbender if ever there was a
perfect animated series it might just be
Avatar in case you need a bit of a
refresher in the world of Avatar people
live in one of four nations each built
around one of the four traditional
elements you have the water tribes at
the North and South Poles the vast Earth
Kingdom that covers most of the world's
land mass the industrious and aggressive
Fire Nation and The elusive flighty air
Nomad monks some people are born with
the ability to bend one of these four
elements but only one person can master
all four of them that one person is
known as the Avatar and is tasked with
keeping the world in balance as the very
first avatar one explains this is my
mission to use rava's light spirit to
guide the World toward peace each Avatar
is born into a cycle water to Earth to
fire to air so that when the previous
Avatar dies a new one is born in the
next nation and over the course of the
various Seasons we watch as this exact
cycle plays out Avatar Kyoshi from the
earth Kingdom gives way to Roku from the
Fire Nation who then dies and opens the
door to Aang from the air Nomads and
finally Avatar Korra from the water
tribe it's a great setup that allows for
stories and characters outside of the
original series to be explored expanding
the world even further I mean that's
basically what happened with the sequel
series The Legend of Korra and it
appears to be Nickelodeon's strategy
with the franchise moving forward there
have been multiple novels and comic
books dedicated to other avatars and
supporting characters they've even
established an entire Production Studio
devoted to more Avatar content rumor has
it that a bunch of this new stuff is
going to focus on different avatars too
sure you'll have the OG's Ang and Korra
as well as the fan favorite kyoji but
also the next Avatar that we haven't
even met yet there's even a live-action
Netflix series on the way here's hoping
it goes better than the last one he was
bending tiny stones at us from behind a
tree
it really hurt anyway in my excitement
for new Avatar content I decided to go
re-watch the series and catch up on a
bunch of the spin-off stories that
they've released over the years and you
know what theorists the more and more I
look the more and more I realize that
having an avatar sucks this world is so
much worse because of the Avatar cycle
when you really break down what each
Avatar does during their life and how it
compares to what each Avatar is supposed
to be doing you'll realize that each and
every one of them has largely failed
enough so that you kind of gotta ask is
it even worth having an avatar at all
hop aboard your Flying Bison and pour
out some cactus juice loyal theorists
I'm about to bend your ear over this
broken ancient tradition let's start by
setting our ground rules shall we
remember the whole thing about the
Avatar is that their main goal is to
keep the world in Balance both
physically and spiritually what exactly
that means could be up for debate but
the way I see it in Avatar's duties
largely break down into four main tasks
one helping keep International Peace
between the four nations two helping
keep internal peace within each of those
Nations three protecting innocent people
and bringing Justice to the unjust and
four Bridging the Gap between the human
world and the spirit world so let's just
start at the beginning of our list one
of the main parts of an Avatar's duty is
to help keep International Peace between
the four nations and admittedly some of
them are good at it for instance we see
that Aang has helped to set up an
international government to help the
four nations stay at peace with each
other but literally from the opening
seconds of the show we know that at
least one Avatar had a major oopsie in
this field the four nations lived
together in harmony then everything
changed when the Fire Nation attacked
the whole premise of the entire
franchise starts with a giant
International war and it all happened
because of the failure of the avatars on
one hand we could blame Aang who ran
away from his duties which in turn
opened up a power vacuum that allowed
the Hundred Year War to begin but he was
also literally 12 years old at the time
so it's kinda hard to fault him for that
one instead the true failure Falls to
Aang's predecessor Avatar Roku Roku was
childhood friends with fire lord sozen
the fire lord who started the war and
what's worse Roku knew that sozin wanted
to conquer these other nations I've been
thinking we should share this Prosperity
with the rest of the world in our hands
as the most successful Empire in history
it's time we expanded it so what did
Roku do to stop it yeah he basically
gave sosin a slap on the wrist and a
Stern talking to by his own admission
roku's indecisiveness and let's be
honest favoritism to his friend and home
nation was a huge weakness which
ultimately led to tons of unnecessary
death in my life I tried to be
disciplined and show restraint but it
backfired if I had been more decisive
and acted sooner I could have stopped
Susan and stopped the war before it
started instead his actions led to
sozin's betrayal his own death and a war
that lasted Generations his failure led
to the complete annihilation of the air
Nation as well as all the loss of life
that comes with war of Conquest it's not
exactly gonna be making watch Mojo's top
10 list of moments that brought balance
to the world and here's the thing we
don't have to look at Roku or Aang to
see the Avatar's failures here in the
prequel novels we learned that Avatar
Zito the Fire Nation Avatar before Roku
was born into a time of great Strife for
the nation and instead of working
internationally like most other avatars
Zito decided to focus on the domestic
politics becoming a bureaucrat within
the Fire Nation to help his people
though he helped Shepherd the Fire
Nation back to Prosperity he did this at
the expense of all the the other nations
this eventually led to an event known as
the Platinum Affair shortly after his
death which saw the Fire Nation and
water tribes secretly backing a
challenger to the Earth Kingdom Throne
when this was discovered it led to all
three nations becoming incredibly
isolationists because of this Zito's
immediate successor The Heir Nomad
Avatar Yang Chen would look back on
Zito's Legacy as Messi so as you can
already start to see having one person
solely responsible for policing the
entire bending world is like an
impossible task time is gonna be the
Avatar's most limited resource and the
decisions that they make on how to spend
that time inevitably means that they're
gonna have to sacrifice one major part
of their Duty obviously for Zito
focusing all of his attention on
bringing prosperity to the Fire Nation
meant that he let conflict arise within
other kingdoms with the Platinum Affair
we see a similar situation arise in the
Avatar Kyoshi books The Avatar before
her had a singular focus on dealing with
the spiritual duties of the role this
meant that he neglected his
responsibilities as a politician his
neglect of the physical world allowed
the Earth Kingdom to become destabilized
by infighting and Kyoshi was basically
forced to spend her entire life cleaning
up that mess but don't feel too bad for
her she caused even more problems than
she solved case in point chin the
Conqueror now this guy was a warlord
standing up against a corrupted King
that said chin was far from a hero as
Kyoshi herself says a horrible Tyrant
chin was expanding his army to all
corners of the continent this seems like
the exact sort of situation where an
avatar should stand up and help make
peace right a rebellion is threatening
to destabilize an entire Kingdom and
both sides are led by awful people the
keeper of peace and balance should
probably be looking into solving this
issue even Kyoshi herself says chin the
Conqueror threatened to throw the world
out of balance there's that word balance
so what did kiyoshi do to stop chin
nothing literally nothing chin was able
to conquer almost the entire continent
Kyoshi only decided to step in when he
showed up at her doorstep to take over
the peninsula that she called home I
warned him that I would not sit
passively while he he took our home yeah
sure kiyoshi looks like you were getting
right to that so now that chin is
literally right in front of her you
would think that this is a good
opportunity to try and stop his conquest
and restore balance to the Earth Kingdom
nope Kyoshi uses her power to disconnect
the peninsula from the mainland and then
proceeds to yielded out into the middle
of the ocean seriously in what's
arguably the most impressive display for
an Avatar's powers that we see
throughout the entire franchise all
Kyoshi does is pull a giant eye imma
head out Chin's Conquest was only
stopped because he was too stubborn to
get out of kyoshi's way falling to his
death as Kyoshi Island was being formed
but I assure you I would have done
whatever it took to stop chin really
Kyoshi sure looks like he got some
massive revisionist history going on
there because he didn't do a gosh darn
thing in the months leading up to him
coming to your Peninsula and that
philosophy runs deep in the village that
Kyoshi leaves behind towards the
beginning of The Last Airbender team
Avatar lands on Kyoshi Island for The
Guiding wisdom of all the Kyoshi stanzas
yeah it's not my problem kiyoshi stayed
out of the war so far and we intend to
keep it that way heck even the Earth
Kingdom capital's catchphrase there's no
war embossing say follows the same
attitude ignore the problem deny close
your eyes and it just goes away
admittedly things seem to go much better
under roku's tenure and after Aang ends
the Hundred Year War things again seem
to go smoothly but under Korra their
civil conflict after civil conflict she
was Avatar during the water tribe Civil
War under her watch the Red Lotus
assassinates the Earth Queen and in the
aftermath korres in action due to injury
and PTSD lets kuvira seize control of a
great deal of the earth Kingdom not a
great track record and a long sequence
of avatars dropping the ball so now
let's move on to our next criteria
protecting the innocent and bringing
Justice to the unjust this one's a bit
harder to judge because we don't see a
lot of the day-to-day lives of each
Avatar and well yeah we do see some
heroic moments like Aang fighting a cone
and Korra chasing down Bender criminals
in the streets of Republic City there's
a rotten core here that starts to peek
through the deeper we get into the
franchise most of the legend of koras
plot revolves around the idea of justice
and what it takes to defend everyone
chorus first major adversary Amman is
the leader of a group called The
equalists Who are all about leveling the
playing field between Benders and
non-benders by taking away the ability
to bend sound insane it is but the
movement is shown to resonate with a lot
of Republic City's citizens life in the
world of Avatar can be incredibly hard
for non-benders even in the new
supposedly harmonious society that Aang
created if you're a bender you have easy
access to jobs power plants use
firebenders to operate trains are
powered by earthbenders and policemen
are almost exclusively metal Benders
vendors also have a much easier time
committing acts of violence as were
frequently shown groups of violent
Benders like the triple threat Triad the
Red Lotus heck even the Republic City
police who treat the use of force like
it's second nature non-benders are
overlooked they're ignored they're
frequently threatened in one particular
scene Republic City's metal bending
police force heard a group of
non-benders like cattle using Force to
break up a non-violent protest these
people are targeted because the police
force has turned off the power to their
homes and they're peacefully resisting
being profiled as members of man's
Uprising just because they aren't
Benders a woman in the crowd makes a
desperate plea for Cora's help saying
please help us you're our Avatar too and
Cora does help kinda unfortunately for
the Common People Cora considers the
issue resolved after she outs Amman as a
bender and a fraud effectively derailing
a movement that began and grew thanks to
a genuine concern from a huge portion of
Republic City's non-bending population
so that one doesn't look all that great
for Cora but when you think about it
this is ang City he created the system
that Korra inherited in fact this goes
well beyond just Cora and Ang the
imbalance between Benders and
non-benders is a failure of every Avatar
before them who popped up were exploited
the same system which brings us back to
kiyoshi who honestly might have been the
worst of the bunch see Kyoshi had
herself a rough childhood she was an
orphan working as a servant until it was
discovered that she was the Avatar she
later joined a criminal gang that was
founded by her parents and it's not like
they suddenly stopped doing crimes after
the Avatar joined nope they decided to
involve kiyoshi in the crimes and that's
not all Yoshi's youthful anger heavily
informed her way of thinking even after
learning that she was the Avatar her
thoughts were more centered on Revenge
than Duty the rise of Kyoshi states that
quote her hunger to learn all four
elements had nothing to do with becoming
a fully realized Avatar fire air and
water were simply more weapons she could
bring to bear on a single Target end
quote and much later in her life she was
so unbothered by taking a life that she
didn't see a difference between
accidents and intentional killings you
didn't really kill technically he
fell to his own Doom because he was too
stubborn to get out of the way
personally I don't really see the
difference as for protecting the
innocent here again we have some
problems in Shadow of Kyoshi kiyoshi
threatens to crush a mother and her
adult son to death with a boulder while
trying to squeeze a false confession out
of him for something they didn't do but
her single worst decision is revealed in
the canonical Flash game escape from the
spirit world it's here that Kyoshi
confesses to Aang her biggest failure
see one of the earth Kings during
kiyoshi's life was incredibly unpopular
his leadership was seen as ineffective
and corrupt and it eventually led to a
has an uprising against him during the
riots the king ordered kiyoshi to put
the uprising down and to her credit she
refused instead she encouraged the king
to listen to the Grievances of the
people and find compromise seems pretty
good so far right but here's the thing
Kyoshi admits that she didn't like the
people standing up against the kingdom
in fact throughout the whole story
Kyoshi seems less concerned about the
human rights abuses committed by the
king and more concerned that the
peasants are destroying historical
artifacts and upsetting the stability of
the monarchy so in exchange for the king
listening to his people and ending the
riots Kyoshi agrees to train an elite
group of earthbenders for him they would
be quote silent precise and feared by
all it was a forest that would
eventually be known as the Dai Lee yup
you remember those creepy secret police
from the Animated Series the ones with
the rock gloves whose loyalty could be
bought and sold and who sided with Azula
and the Fire Nation during the invasion
of bossing say they were kyoshi's idea
she even admits that she regrets not
foreseeing the long-term consequences of
giving future Earth Kingdom monarchs
access to an elite secret police force
but here's the thing that move didn't
make sense even in her time period this
King the one that was ready to crush his
own people he shouldn't have had access
to that secret police force either
imagine what he would have had him do to
The Peasants if they were around to
begin with then again when you're as
powerful as Kyoshi and you treat your
powers like a big old Hammer I guess
everything looks like a nail so again
for a lot of the avatars protecting the
innocent and bringing Justice to the
unjust is just a bust so that's three
for three where a ton of avatars fail
but what about our fourth criteria here
Bridging the Gap and keeping the peace
between the human and spirit worlds this
is basically the thing that avatars are
supposed to be good at surely there
isn't a legacy of failure here too well
you would think and then you would be
wrong we hear in the prequel novel
dedicated to Avatar Yang Chen that when
humans and Spirits came into conflict
she would strike Bargains that would get
the spirits to leave humans alone so
long as they took care of the physical
world and of course humans did not live
up to their end of the deal as a result
Spirits wound up committing a lot of
violence against humans who broke their
oads this in turn created a huge mess
for the next Avatar correct to clean up
we discover in the Kyoshi novels that
Avatar Couric would end up spending most
of his short life fighting the dark
Spirits empowered by Yang Chen's
decisions finally let's skip forward to
Avatar Korra who might just have been
the Avatar to fail the most at this one
at the end of The Legend of Korra season
2 Korra is subdued by her uncle unalak
who's merged with the dark spirit vatu
unalak is able to rip the Avatar Spirit
rava from korra's body severing her
Connection to the Past avatars forever
thousands of years worth of knowledge
snuffed out in an instant additionally
during this battle we witness a world
shifting event called the harmonic
convergence basically a portal opens
between the spirit and human worlds
allowing people and Spirits to pass
freely between them at the end of it
Cora decides to keep the portals to the
spirit world open a decision that
reverses The Stance of the very first
Avatar and Faithfully combines the human
and spirit Worlds at first glance it
seems brilliant right when the peaceful
coexistence between humans and Spirits
create a more meaningful bond between
them well not necessarily the unforeseen
consequence of these two vastly
different worlds colliding is
complicated and really does doesn't
scream balance first the overlapping
geographies of the world create huge
territory issues houses in Republic City
are overrun by Vines and entire city
blocks are destabilized doesn't matter
if you're a bender or a non-bender
finding your living room destroyed and
you're building about to collapse
definitely on the list of top 5 worst
breakfast time surprises and second
harmonic convergence gives Zahir one of
the most dangerous Warriors in the world
the power of air bending which he
promptly uses to start assassinating
world leaders and throw the world out of
balance I'm gonna chalk that one up as a
big oopsie there Cora when you stop and
look at the totality of what we know
about the avatars one thing becomes
clear time and time again this is a
vicious cycle every single one of these
avatars dealt with difficult issues but
their Solutions just wound up creating
more problems for the immediate
successor Zito focused too much on his
own country Yang Chen has to deal with
and break down isolationist policies
Yang Chen helps make peace between the
four nations but at the cost of angering
the spirits well kurick has to spend his
life battling dark spirits and winds up
neglecting the real world Nations
hurricane dies early in battle with
Spirits leaving an unstable political
situation Kyoshi creates a secret police
to try and paper over the problems of
her country Roku shows favoritism to his
home nation Aang has to deal with a
century-long war and the death of his
entire people all of them ignore
non-benders Cora has to deal with the
Fallout and the equalists the Avatar's
cycle is a cycle of violence it is a
broken system and honestly that makes
perfect sense ask yourself why does the
Avatar have to have a monopoly on
balance in this world the very concept
of the Avatar is imbalanced at the end
of the day the avatars possess the power
of a god literally a god of light but
they're still only humans Aang was a 12
year old kid faced with solving a
hundred-year-old War Kyoshi was a poor
orphan eventually she's gonna defend her
home so it wasn't ripped away again Roku
was friends with sozin of course he's
gonna be slow to action and more lenient
in his judgment one person holding that
much power that much influence to recipe
for disaster feel like I've heard this
somewhere before with great power
it's great responsibility in the end the
really successful avatars or maybe the
least unsuccessful avatars are the ones
that don't do it alone Aang Saves the
World from firelord ozai because he
trusts his friends to help get the job
done Saka Toff Suki Zuko and Katara are
all off playing Key Parts and stopping
the Fire Nation while Aang has his rad
Dragon Ball Z fight against ozai and
those friends are just as essential
after the war in helping him restore
balance too his friends help make and
keep the International Peace all in ways
that Aang wouldn't be able to do on his
own it just goes to show that
controlling all the elements in this
world is meaningless if you don't also
control the element of friendship but
hey if you want more avatar The Last
Airbender content right now go check out
our previous Theory talking about the
science of water bending yeah believe it
or not but what you see Katara and Aang
doing in the series isn't that far out
of the realm a possibility or if you
want something a little different I
actually teamed up with Nickelodeon
themselves and did a video breaking down
whether or not a creature as big as oppa
could actually fly it's different but it
was a really fun collab with the people
who made this show happen in the first
place as always don't forget to
subscribe with all that new Avatar
content you know we're gonna have a ton
more to cover here on the channel but
until then my friends remember it's all
just a theory a film Theory and cuts